ايام دقيقه يشهدها الاقتصاد العالمي سببها
بالخط العريض ازمه مصرف سيليكون فالي
البنك الذي اعلن بشكل مفاجئ عدم قدرته على
تغطيه ودائع العملاء المصرف المتخصص في
تمويل الشركات الناشئه في امريكا والعالم
تحول في غضون ايام لبنك مفلس بعد اربعين
عاما من الخدمات المصرفيه الانهيار
المصرفي الاخطر منذ 15 عاما زلزل الاقتصاد
العالمي العيون اتجهت لناحيه الخوف من
ازمه ماليه عالميه جديده الخوف دفع
الحكومه الامريكيه لوضع يدها على المصرف
واعده بالوفاء بالتزاماته للعملاء لكن
السوق خسر اكبر احد الممولين مخاطره في
الدخول بالمشاريع وتمويلها
[موسيقى]
في عام
1983 كانت بدايه الرحله المحفوفه بالمخاطر
لبنك وادي السيليكون الامريكي الذي اختار
المخاطره بتمريرات ضخمه للشركات التقنيه
ليزيد نشاطه منتصف التسعينات مع الثوره
التكنولوجيه حيث اصبح الممول الرئيسي
للشركات الناشئه في هذا المجال توسع
سيليكون فالي خارجا من اطار امريكيته توسع
الى الهند الصين واوروبا وبعدد موظفين وصل
الى اكثر من 8000 موظف وباصول ماليه تصل
لاكثر من 200 مليار دولار امريكي فضلا عن
30 الف شركه حصلت على تمويلها منه في
العقد الثاني من الالفيه الجديده تحول
مصرف سيليكون فالي الى احد اكبر البنوك
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
على كل في الاستوديو تنظمي الينا اقتصاديه
فرح مراد فرح يسعد صباحك نورتنا من جديد
لو نبدا بالحديث للمشاهدين ولكل بدهم
يفهموا ما هي اسباب انهيار سيليكون فاني
البنك يعني بدنا نرجع شوي كمان للسابع
لنشوف كيف التسلسل وصلنا لهذه النتيجه
بطبيعه الحال خلال فتره كورونا بدنا نتذكر
كان في عنا سيوله دخت في الاسواق بطريقه
كتير كبيره نحن عم نحكي عن دولار وصلت في
الاسواق هيدي عملت نوع من النمو فانا
اعتبره او اصطناعي لانه طبيعه الحال كنا
قاعدين بالمنادر لشركات كانت موقفه فمن
بعد ما توجهنا لفتح الاسواق وبعد ما شفنا
هالتضخم المرتفع جدا اللي كان عم يوصل
يعني اخر شيء وصلنا هلا لسته بالميه
كاركان تضخم كان لابد من الفيدراليه يتوجه
الى سياسه متشدده بدنا نكون عم نعقد
الكمون والامور ولكن بدنا نعرف انه كل ما
نكون نحن عم نتوجه لرفع الفائده مما يسمى
بالسياسه متشدده من الفيدرالي هالشي بيكون
عم بياثر على السندات الخزانه اسعارها
بتتراجع ونحن عم انه خلال فتره كورونا كان
في عنا سيوله كبيره سيليكون فالي مثلا بنك
كان نوعا ما متوجه على قطاع التكنولوجيا
كان عم يستفيد منها السيوله العاليه وكان
عم يستثمر متل ما كل البنوك بتعمل بتستثمر
اموال الموجعين في مشاريع او في كمان في
الخزانه كان سعرها اقل وقت اشتريناهم
ارتفعت اسعارهن بالوقت اللي يعني بطبيعه
الحال صار سعرهن اقل وكل ما يكون في طلب
منك ليكونوا عم ياخدوا اموالهم كل ما تكون
البنك مضطر انه يبيع هيدي السنه ديت بسعر
اقل وهون كنا عم نشوف الفجوه في الميزانيه
لكن تعليق ابرز اسباب الازمه على سياسه
الفيدرالي هل يعني بان بنوك اخرى ستلقى
المصير نفسه اي تاثير الدومينو على القطاع
المصرفي يعني هذا المخاوف اللي عم نشوفها
هو بالفعل مش عم نحكي صار في عندنا ثلاث
بنوك كمان عم تشوف نفس التاثير عم تشوف
توجهنا الى القاهره الاوروبيه وكمان عم
نشوف نفس الشيء بسويس كود مثلا هلا عم
نحكي عن الموضوع
فكل هذه المواضيع بطبيعه الحال رح تكون عم
بتاثر سيليكون فالي بشكل خاص عم يتاثر
كمان بتراجع قطاع التكنولوجيا بتراجع
الاكتتاب كمان في شركات التكنولوجيا ولكن
بشكل عام بالفعل مشان هيك هلا السوق بلش
يسعر من رفع 50 نقطه اساس في الاجتماع
القادم
اول بعد عم يحكي انه ما يكون في ارتفاع
اطلاقا لاسعار الفائده فطبيعه الحال
فدرالي راح يكون هذه الازمه فرح ما
المتوقع من سلوكيات المستثمرين والمذيعين
في البنوك عم نشوف تراجع في معنويات بدنا
نسميه الاصول الخطره بشكل عام يمكن عم
نحكي عن الاسهم كنا عم نحكي عن مثلا سلع
الطاقه النفط كل هذه الامور عم تتراجع
بالوقت اللي عم نشوف توجه الى الذهب مثلا
اللي هو المنازل امن كمان يوم امس كنا عم
تشوف ارتفاع في مؤشر الدولار كمان نوعا
يعتبر ملاذ امن ما بين العملات كمان ارتفع
نوعا ما على رغم من تراجع كبير خلال فتره
العامل الماضي وهذا العام كمان يعتبر
ملازمه فيه وجه المخاوف اللي عم نشوفها
بالاسواق طبيعه الحال الى ان نرى على
الرغم من انه الفيدراليا وكمان الخزينه
نوعا ما عم بيساعدوا القطاع عم نحكي عن
بيل اوت في الوقت الحالي ولكن يبدو ان
المستثمرين الى ان يرثوا لا يمكن اوضح
يمكن
المتوقع اكثر اننا عم نشوف ضغط على الاسهم
وارتفاع في الملفات الامنه بس فرح يعني
صار في حاله من الذعر اليوم وذكرت بازمه
افلاس سليمان 2008 هل العالم مقبل على هذه
الازمه بس في مبالغات اليوم هلا عم نشوف
التاثير الاكبر هو على البنوك اللي نوعا
ما كانت عم تقدم سعر فائده اعلى كمان لانه
لتعود شوي على الخسائر اللي كانت عم تقول
فيها او لتكون شوي اتراكتور اكثر كمان
للمستثمرين يبدو البنوك الكبيره الى الوقت
الحالي محميه مختلف نوعا ما عم تشوفي ب
2008 كان بالعكس للبنوك
اخر خصوصي انه في عنا سيوله مرتفعه جدا في
الاسواق لازم نكون عم ننتظر كمان اجتماع
الفيدرالي نشوف هل سيقلصه السيوله اكثر ام
سيتركوها كمان فهمت انه تنصحيني ان نلجا
للذهب كما لدى يعني طبيعه الحال دايما
وابدا وتكون في توتر في الاصوات في نفور
من المخاطر
يستفيد وكمان بدنا نضيف لها تضخم الذي لا
يزال موجود وكمان على المستوى المتوسطي